[Music]
[Applause]
hello Jesus coffee you my name is NaN
Ellison and I am gonna make all of you
fall in love with polyhedra so your
first question is probably what is a
polyhedron well to do to answer that we
can go to Wikipedia which states that a
polyhedron is a solid in three
dimensions with flat faces straight
edges and sharp corners or vertices for
example some of you may know about the
Platonic solids such as the cube and the
tetrahedron
they each have a single type of face in
are really some metrics that whichever
way you turn them you still get the same
figure
there are also their relatives the
Archimedean solids which can have more
than one type type of face so you can
have maybe triangles and Pentagon's
together but they're still highly
symmetric and you can still rotate them
and still get the same shape there are
also the Johnson solids which can be
made of any irregular polygon in
whatever order so these can range from a
simple square pyramid to a triangular
have a span no rotunda but anyways I
love polyhedra and I'm not the only one
they've been used in art and
architecture and games and film for
centuries they're beautiful and
symmetrical and found in nature but
they're simple but somehow extremely
alien to us but there's another reason
that I like them and it has to do with
Pokemon and this isn't really it's kind
of silly but not really
both polyhedra and pokemon have lots of
data associated with them polyhedra have
like different groups that are in
symmetries nets falling Pokemon have
different types and egg groups and
movesets varieties there's like a
buttload of each of them a lot of unique
qualia in Pokemon to learn about and
discover and finally and most
importantly to me they both evolving to
each other in really interesting ways
for Pokemon
was pretty straightforward the Pokemon
usually just gets bigger and stronger
sometimes he can branch off and involve
to do two different Pokemon or more but
with polyhedra the transformations are
more complicated you can trim them off
or cup and paste them together or do
this weird twisty thing called cinema
fication and there's a lot to discover
in the lark to learn and when I was a
kid I'd spend hours poring over
different polyhedra websites looking at
different miles and VR and origami and
which was really fun but it also made me
kind of sad because the thing was lots
of people know know and love about
Pokemon me included in fact I would put
them on so much that the first thing I
did when I got to Europe was catch mr.
mime and took him on go because it's a
regional exclusive and they just had to
but not as many people know about
polyhedra and that's kind of a shame and
kind of sad so I decided that it would
be my mission to make the best polyhedra
website that ever was to catch them is
my real quest and to understand them as
my cause and today I'm gonna share with
you my journey to becoming a polyhedron
master but before that before talking
about code let's talk about some of the
other ways that I've tried to bring my
love of polyhedra to life
I want to through several attempts the
first of first of which is origami it's
really cool and RC I see lots of
collections online and he thought you
know might not make my own I mean like
one cube and then I got a paper cut and
I didn't want to do it anymore and I got
really tired of it really quickly so I
thought maybe I could 3d print them and
like make cool jewelry or something you
know 3d printing technology has advanced
a lot you just need to upload a model on
shapeways and do-- my god it's too
expensive so the next step which
logically followed was writing polyhedra
fanfiction but the less then less said
about that phrase the better and after
this I decide you know what let me just
let me just make a website that's why I
know how to do so I got started our
journey begins in May 2015 I was working
as an internal tools engineer making
code for engineers to make code for
engineers to make code for other people
and
really felt like I was this peak to you
and then generator just drying away so
wait so I asked my boss I really wanted
to do friend in and I asked him can I
work on friend that stuff and he
eventually he got back to me and said
well you know I heard you like this we
have a new project coming up I have just
the thing for you Jenkins oh it's a UI
you should work on that
needless to say I was not very happy
with that so I decided to take matters
into my own hands and what better way to
do that than by making something that I
already love and when I started I had a
bunch of really big brain ideas about
collecting every single fact about
polyhedra on Wikipedia and putting them
on my page I wanted VR I wanted to do
cool transformations transforming them
into one another but that I still had my
job doing Jenkins or whatever and I
realized that you know in Pokemon before
you challenge the Elite Four you have to
get your first gym badge so that's why I
did I narrowed it down to something
simple just a modern update or version
of those sites that I loved seeing as a
kid where I could see my favorite
polyhedra I didn't want to make the most
myself so I just downloaded them from
one of my favorite websites 3j s was
kind of too low level for me and I
didn't want to have to struggle with
lighting and buffers and stuff and what
I really knew was d3 and it's data
mining data binding model to SVG and
luckily I found a library called x3 Dom
which let me express 3d modeling data as
Dom knows much like SVG so I could use
that
what with d3 and it worked perfectly so
it took me about a week of part-time
work to get it working and I'll just
bring this over here and you can see um
I have a little tetrahedron a cube an
Archimedean solid different Johnson
solids but that was kind of it let me
close this out I showed it to a few
friends but kind of left it it was a
good start but it was also like too
simple and not really interactive and I
found myself being unsatisfied by it so
fast forward two years later I got fired
because I hated Jenkins
oh-hi took a somatic sabbatical and I
made a video game I wrote more
fanfiction and I started a new job where
I actually got to befriend it it was
angular one but baby steps
I did that for a few months and we were
in the process of switching out our
front-end to from angular to react and I
thought that you know I should be a good
little employee and learn about it in
the side project but I didn't want to do
like the basic to-do app that everyone
does when learning a new friend and
framework so I thought why not make my
old polyhedra viewer in to learn react
after all Nintendo has been remaking the
same Pokemon game for decades and we
still love them so I got started and it
turns out that react is being a
declarative framework is also it also
works really well with X freedom just
like the screen moreover I found that
react made it a lot easier to add
interactivity such as adding a
configuration panel or a search bar or
an actual index page where you can see
my collection at once and I don't have a
live version of this running but you
know again I showed it to my boss and my
teammates and that was kind of it oh
that's really cool now now get back to
work um it was more interactive but it
was just still aesthetic you can change
the cars but that doesn't really tell
you that much about polyhedra
like what I really wanted to do was
these cool transitions but I didn't have
time because I was busy refactoring an
angular app so I have to put in the
wanking das wird another couple of
months in October I left my job due to
burnout and depression and kind of just
wanted to take a break from all the
coding and focus on my other hobbies
like fanfiction but
somehow writing Polydor fanfiction did
not make me forget about polyhedra and
old habits die hard and they kept coming
back to the polyhedron project and
making improvements to it more
specifically I wanted to arrange the
polyhedron into sort of a periodic table
based on their properties and seeing all
the polyhedra related to each other and
I correlated it like that made me think
you know what why not just do what I
wanted to do in the first place I
finally feel like I have the skills to
do it and more importantly I have the
time so I got started in this on the
long laborious process of making my
final evolution of my polyhedra viewer I
have no idea what I'm doing but the very
first step was to really determine what
operations are possible and actually
valid after all not every Pokemon can
involve or combine into one another and
you don't want to allow freeform
transformations between polyhedra as
cool as they might look I already had a
pretty good idea about what
relationships are from making that
periodic table and when you see a bunch
of Alliance connecting dots like this
you are thinking of you're looking at a
state machine or a graph with the
polyhedra as nodes and the operations as
edges and there's a pretty
straightforward way to represent this as
an object you can it's just like an
object of an object of a list of objects
you just label it with metadata to
differentiate between multiple results
but there's a lot of polyhedra and a lot
of relationships to encode and it's all
really but luckily it's all really
structured and through an advanced
programming technique called for loops
we can save time from manually coding
the entire graph alright so now that we
have this graph we can figure out what
operation and what options to transform
a polyhedron into another one and this
lets you do cool stuff like disabling
operations if they're invalid you can
automatically test whether applying an
operation leaves a result that matches
the model that we currently have you
could mock the actual animations and
just click around and load the next
polyhedron instead of animating
so now that we have that out of the way
let's talk about the actual transitions
at the beginning I again I didn't know
what I was doing I didn't know what
operations or how many I wanted so it
would be nice to have kind of an
abstract interface that I can just plug
in so I had to think of myself think to
myself what is a transition well let's
look at what we're actually doing
we're interpolating vertices we're
moving them from a start to an end
position and at either of those points
they might be overlapping the faces and
edges are defined by their by the
versed's so we don't they don't change
even if they're invisible at some point
and or overlap but there's a problem
with doing duplication and that's that
we want to be able to chain operations
like this we want to be able to blow
stuff up and contract stuff and it would
be too complicated to keep track of all
the duplicated vertices for every single
operation that we had so we pull out
nulled switcheroo much as it's
impossible for you to tell which one's
the bulbs are in which one there's a
shape shifted ditto it's impossible for
you to tell which one of these is
duplicates but one of them has actually
extra vertices and faces and we can
actually define an interface that and as
long as our operation functions return
this interface if we can animate all of
them the same way and the algorithm is
for one replace of vertices with the
duplicated versions which is defined for
operation interpolate from the start to
the end vertices and then switch out the
end result with a deduplicated version
and this is kind of what it looks like
in code you just use whatever state
function to and set it to the start you
interpolate and then send it to the
deduplicated end and finally you just
need an interpolation function and
there's a lot of libraries that you can
use for animation in JavaScript half of
these probably don't exist anymore
because the animation in JavaScript is a
crapshoot so or if you're like me and
you're cool you could Google grid Quest
animation frame and roll out your own
it's great so we have our little
animation but we don't have anything to
test it on so let's talk about the
option or actual operations that we're
going to make I'm not going to go over
all of them but I wanted to share one
example
it's kind of easy and it's this
operation called rectifying what you're
doing is turning this cube into this
shape called a cuboctahedron
you start out with a cube you mark the
midpoints you draw a line between them
and then you kind of cut them across and
slice them up but we don't want to just
like go back and forth we want a smooth
transition so what we have to do in
order to get this smooth transition to
animate it we duplicate each vertex
twice and so that there are three Versys
at each corner we pulled them to the
midpoints and then if there are two sets
of vertices we consolidate them into one
so the algorithm the algorithm is just
duplicate and then map to the end the
duplication is kind of annoying and not
really interesting it's just making sure
that all the old stuff and maps to the
new stuff and allow cross referencing
indices finding that adjacent vertex is
just picking the one that here is not
one of your duplicates and then
calculating the midpoint through a math
library and finally you put it all
together and return the interface that
we just defined and here we go squash
and stretch
that really wasn't done impressed as I
know why you all are crowd clapping so I
think I made about like half the
operations before realizing math is kind
of hard y'all in particular the way that
you usually represent polyhedral
geometry is through a list of
coordinates which is and a list of faces
that refer to the indices of the
vertices are in the faces which is fine
for 3d modeling but that doesn't always
translate well to the math stuff that we
want to do for instance how do you tell
an array to calculate the centroid of a
face or a combined two polyhedra
together so that the selected faces
overlap or apply the same transformation
for the selected pieces or pyramids of
the polyhedron in reference to the
center of the polyhedron it's hard and
what you end up doing is a lot of index
manipulation you're saying the face
indices that refer to these vertex
indices you have indices of indices and
I'm so tired of hearing the word indices
did you know that the plural of indexes
indices well now I do but how do we
solve this problem well for Pokemon
different types of Pokemon are strong
against each other if you're finding a
water pokemon you have to use an
electric pokemon because that's what's
effective so and likewise different
types of programming have different
solutions in this case the solution that
we're going to use is the object
oriented programming they definitely
have their weaknesses but they're useful
here you can of course encapsulate
methods in the polyhedra that makes
sense to them like getting a centroid or
like combining two polymers together you
can also keep track of metadata like the
custom data like vector format that the
vertices are stored in and in particular
this is there is a really useful
structure called the doubly connected
edge list
it's a linked list where each vertex
edge and face has references to adjacent
facets and it was pretty easy to
implement using the class structure now
I could have stopped making the
polyhedron the class stopped at making
the polyhedron the class but Team Rocket
could have stopped trying to catch speak
to you all but if they did a Nintendo
can make money making the Pokemon enemy
so I made everything in class the
vertices the edges the faces I have no
idea if that was a good idea or not but
I didn't have to say the word indices
ever again so I was
happy but even with the data structures
a lot of problems are still really hard
for example determining whether
something is an Archimedean solid
sometimes operations do different things
based on whether you're a platonic or
Archimedean solid and naively you can
just check if the adjacent pieces of
each vertex has the same configuration
but there's this [ __ ] called an
elongated square jeribai cupola which
looks like an Archimedean solid and but
it's just slightly twisted and its
really annoying it's like the mr. mime
of polyhedra and to do it right it's a
whole lot more involved so how do we
solve this problem well in Pokemon
there's a mythical Pokemon called you
that you can only ever get from going to
an event in Tokyo but when I played the
first Pokemon game I couldn't go to
Tokyo because that was eight years old
so you can just use this cake which
called missingno to get the mu much
easier so let's just see we know that
are only thirteen Archimedean solids
that's been known since the Renaissance
it's actually been proven so since we
have that list am I not just still with
them all and check whether it's at one
of those and this turns out making these
shortcuts was actually a lot really
useful in a lot of areas because there
are a lot of places where it's
significantly easier to code when you
know what thing you're turning into when
you have the graph anyways that's log
math so let's go focus on art like I
said in the beginning a lot of these
polyhedra sites are really old they're
often done by math professors on their
spare time for example this is kind of
the state of the art of polyhedra
websites I took this screenshot not in
1995 but two days ago
they're so old and a lot of them don't
even work anymore you can't even see the
polyhedra models or upload them or view
them so I got to work designing to make
sure that my website can be a new
destination for polyhedron lovers I
wanted to make sure that worked on
mobile phones so you can play with it
anywhere or if you don't have access to
a desktop I wanted to make sure that
there are a lot of visual aids who you
can press around on the buttons even if
you don't know what they really do or if
you don't know the math lingo and I made
sure to pass all my google lighthouse
tests to make sure that you can use the
site even if you have a bad connection
or you have a disability or if you don't
have Wi-Fi on a plane and you really
need to get screenshots for your
presentation in Gia's coffee you so
after many months of Polish and hunt
work I was ready to present it so here
is a poly fewer here's the home page you
have that periodic table of polyhedra
showing all of them let's start with a
simple tetrahedron you can truncate it
sharpen it you can augment it or
diminish it you can do that operation
that we coded together called
rectification and you can do that
animation where you expand the
polyhedron and you can contract it back
into its tool a cube and finally you can
do this weird thing called snub if
occasion where as you can see is
actually expanding out the faces but
adding us like twist them and you can
also filter search and filter change the
colors the color thing is like on my
other screen or look at info about each
polyhedron anyways the link is up over
there and so you can just play around
with it instead of listening to me for
the rest of the talk
yeah so I kinda released it and expected
it to just sink after all polyhedra are
really obscure and the last couple of
times that really stood I just showed it
to a couple of friends and they're like
oh that's nice get back to work but to
my surprise a lot of people loved it a
lot of people I admired on in the
development community retweeted it I got
interviewed by math publications I was
able to connect with a lot of people
both in the tech and art and math space
who really enjoyed it I had parents
telling me their kids can stop playing
with it
teachers saying they want to use it to
teach their kids about polyhedra in the
classroom I was able to learn about
other cool polyhedra projects by people
obsessed with other aspects of polyhedra
or other polyhedra and I was able to
connect with artists who loved polyhedra
and expressed it in a different way
through their art but at the end of my
long long journey the message that won
in part is even if you think your
passions are too obscure or weird
there's always a way to share it with
the world and make other people fall in
love with them as well
no matter if it's polyhedra or Pokemon
and it's okay to take your time to
evolve and grow whatever your passions
are to transform them and eventually I'm
sure that you can create something
amazing thank you
[Music]